cette nouvelle souche que mon revendeur m'a donnée
m'a aidé à rentrer à la maison
hé les gars qui ont des problèmes ici
quel est le problème pouvez-vous m'aider à rentrer à la
maison
alors vous auriez pu être spécial mais
vous n'avez rien fait d'otage que
vous auriez pour un [ __ ] d'exercice qu'il a eu
un effet positif sur moi d'
accord un peu vraiment euh les gars à la maison
n'allez pas me tirer dessus vraiment oh elle dit
Christ monsieur je m'excuse pour mon
enfant de cinq ans mauvais garçon tu t'assois
là et tu manges ton poisson bruyant Cena hé
tu es prêt je  je suis les copains pour la vie
il y a une
spirale [ __ ]
hey fais attention avec ça hein non non ça
va c'est pas de l'eau ouais et mon [ __ ] de
nez t'a sorti